um you can ask anybody to put their
mobile phones on sounds or scripts
um
this is part two of our
planning plans committee meeting for the
4th and 5th
of november
and i'll i'll just lastly committee to
introduce them so if you've gone live on
youtube again this morning ask the
committee to introduce themselves that
they
good morning my name is pete watson i
represent broadly good morning my name
is
good morning my name is david mcgough
and i represent biddeford
my name is chris leather and i
represent the northern ward and i'll ask
our officers present to introduce
themselves this morning uh good morning
members members of the public my name is
sean harrington i'm planning manager
foreign council
good morning um my name is stacy dorian
head of legal governance for torres
district council
good morning all right my name is james
jackson i'm a principal planning officer
at torres district council
i'm the true shoutback
good morning my name
good morning is newcomb from german
language
good morning sandra committee clark
good morning kirsty i work in democratic
services
thank you
right well
before we go to the continuation of the
planning applications
we will
tell everybody about the speakers as
they listed this morning
for the
[Music]
month your way
application
we've got ian roach to speak in support
enthusiasm
impulsive speaking support who is the
applicant
and then for the
application for the
key 22 the key and benefit
jenny caroline who was in support was
the applicant
uh nikki buckley in support who's the
applicant as well
and there's a statement from councillor
bushby
which are plenty manageable bring down
thank you right we'll move on to agenda
item 7f
which starts on page
93
and uh
[Music]
thank you thank you chad
uh yes so this is uh item 7f this is
application of 1
o five two one of week 2021
this is a section 73 application for the
variation of conditions
um of an original application which was
outlined which was granted by plans
committee in 2018
and the section 73 of the tiny country
planning act allows
um extant permissions to to be
varied essentially in terms of removal
or variation of the conditions that are
attached to that external commission and
uh members were
minded to resolve to grant approval
today that would result in a new
planning permission uh being issued
and
just to
included with the agenda pack just a
short explanatory note that just
explains the the relationship between
the two
applications here today and
i won't sort of read that out in in full
but just to say that we'll see
the two are linked in terms of one is an
outline application one is a reserved
matters application and together those
two two applications for granted would
form the planning commission um they so
they're linked in that sense but they
are separate applications they're
separate agenda items it would be
possible for for this committee to
approve one and not the other either way
around approve both reviews both
one one doesn't link to the other in
that way so um
that's clear for you
um
just in terms of the nature of the the
the variations that are sought through
section 73 it relates to three
conditions on the
uh original application
and the first one of those is the
condition requiring
reserve matters to be submitted and
approved by the local planning authority
prior to development commencing
the second is a highways related
condition which which sort of sets out
various highways requirements and the
third is the contamination condition
which sets out
requirements for the development of the
site in terms of any contamination
that's found and what the applicant
needs to do
so the
common to all three of these um sort
variations is that it's effectively just
to
alter the wording of those conditions to
ensure that they don't reply to the
whole of the site anymore and the reason
for this is that devonshire homes are
seeking to acquire the land on the
eastern side of monte away but don't
have an interest in the western side and
so
as we stand at the moment that original
outline applies to both parcels of land
and conditions applied to both parcels
of land and so the developer obviously
does not want to be
duty-bound to
have obligations on part of the site
that they have no legal interest in
really so so it really is a
an exercise in in wording to split those
up it would help with conveyancing
clearly down the line in terms of when
these properties are sold in the future
uh it just tidies that out nicely from
us
from that respect really
so in terms of the actual
wording i won't go through that in in
detail but it is set out in your agenda
on pages
96
97
98 and 99
and the proposed wording was called
variations
are those sections just underlined and
set out in its habits
um so you can see they're very very
minor in there in their nature
and obviously in your offices view don't
materially affect
the nature of the development in terms
of what would be built or any impacts of
the development there so so that's what
you're considering for for this item
really
uh next slightly sure
so this is the site location plan this
is the same site location plan as the
original outline this is the variation
so we fall back on those original plans
this shows the
um the two parcels of land to the east
and to the west of monterey way that's
monterey we're going through sort of
north-south routes through the middle of
the site there
the eastern parcel
comprises four parcels of land divided
up by mature hedgerows
and currently quite overgrown in parts
uh some quite significant trees on the
site as well
there's no active agricultural use there
at the moment
uh and access is provided by a gated
access onto mantay away and also a gated
access onto albany stock road on the on
the southern bound trigger
uh we've also got the broadlands
residential estate which borders the
site over to the uh to the west
the um
land to the west of the uh of mount
airway
again there's four parcels of land
separated by fields field boundaries of
varying quality uh some of that is still
in active agricultural use
uh you can see that it wraps around the
existing kingsley house development on
its on its southern edge there that is
um
kingsley house is occupied by the
national autistic society we've got a
residential care facility there
we've got existing vehicle accesses on
either side of kingsley house um both
coming on to alberto scott road one on
the eastern one on the on the west
the majority of the site is reasonably
flat although it does drop away quite
sharply to the east that members may
have served on the on the site visits
earlier this week
um and we've also got um
some existing dwellings to the north
there on mines road and then
on the site boundary it does really
start to fall away quite sharply in
terms of the levels of the site
next slide please sure
this is just a photo so this is the
existing access at top left
onto monte away
in terms of the western parcel of the
site and then we've got the undeveloped
areas of land shown on on those bottom
suture extracts
and so the um
the main material considerations are are
really as per the original outline um
back in 2018 which will applicable
development character and appearance
highways residential amenity
biodiversity blood rest flood risk and
surface water drainage and
infrastructure in 106
and so
as set out in your offices report your
officers do consider that the
proposed variations to the wording
conditions would not have a materially
greater impact
on the environment and the development
is already committed and it's therefore
recommended that permission be granted
subjective conditions set out
in your offices report which are carried
across from the original outline and
varied as proposed by the application
and um also a section 106 to
secure the various items of
infrastructure
which i'll just go through quickly
so they are set out on pages 109 and 110
of
your agenda
and the majority of these again are
carried across from the original section
106 that applied to the site
obviously we've we've had to look at
the the fact that obviously the
developer isn't developing both sides of
the site so it would be unreasonable for
to expect to deliver everything that was
on the original um section 106 but i
think we've reached an appropriate
balance in terms of
allowing that site to come forward and
still ensuring that the
development will make a
valuable contribution to the
infrastructure in the area really so i
think everything in there was carried
across from the original 106 with the
exception of
multi-use games area in the neighborhood
bay area so everything else is on there
which is the primary education
contribution of 4 695
pounds per qualifying dwelling
uh an sen contribution for 48 522 pounds
affordable housing at 20 which is a
split of 75 social rented and 25
intermediate
and we've got 75 000 highways
contribution towards highways
improvement works
and local area for play uh minimum 100
square meters and a local equipped area
of play with a minimum of 400 square
meters
so that's it from from me on this item
if i'm just doing questions i'll be
happy to talk to them okay
thank you james can i just ask the two
speakers you've got this did he enroll
in paul reported yeah this morning
did you want to speak to this or to the
reserve matters application because it
says here that you wanted to speak to
this application
i take it as the reserve matters you
want speed
we would both go to speak just once each
but in relation to both applications so
um
yes yeah either way right okay
fine okay so
thank you james storm our first speaker
then
roach
and if you'd like to come up to the
microphone
[Music]
and speak straight into the end of that
because nobody can hear in here
and uh you've got three minutes thank
you when you settle to
address the commitment
[Music]
and yours your talk will be on both
applications
thank you so thank you good morning
netcasters
my name is ian roach i'm a planning
consultant employed by demonstrating uh
his agent
[Music]
since the summer of 2020 i've been
advising temperature homes on this site
working with their architects and their
engineers to align the development
proposals with the necessary
requirements of the outlying commission
and the policies in your local plan
and together we've also worked very
closely with
your office of mr jackson in a
productive relationship throughout the
comprehensive pre-app process and
through the determination period
mr jackson has already explained how the
first of the two applications the
section 73 application is a necessary
formality because temperature homes will
only acquire and develop the land to the
east mountain away not land to the west
so the second application the reserve
matters is the detailed design
the proposals feature a new road access
off mantello way and into the site
at this location there will be a new
toucan crossing over mantello way
and new bus stop markings
davinci homes will also be widening the
existing foot and cycle way on the
western side of mantello way
and providing a pedestrian link at the
south west corner of the site which is
adjacent to the roundabout
originally the plan had also been to
provide a secondary vehicle access off
the valve disco road something that was
existed in the original outline
application and in policy pid02
however
detailed surveys and design work has
shown that such a proposal would also
have provided a pedestrian footwear
but providing such a footwear would have
also meant loss of about 100 meters of
hedgehog
that would have adversely impacted
biodiversity and completely changed the
character of the lane
that access was also quite unpopular
with the number of local residents
so definitely homes therefore withdrew
that secondary access
in august of this year
the highways proposals i just described
they now agreed with the local highways
authority and your planning officer
indeed all other technical aspects of
the proposals such as drainage are also
agreed with the respective offices and
authorities
back in may we attended a meeting of
biddeford town council to present our
proposals
the town council appreciated the gesture
we made in going to see them
and we appreciate the written support
they have now provided
we also met with representatives of
kingsley house and the national autistic
society back in april
we listened to their comments we refined
our construction methodology
specifically adding additional fencing
and scaffolding screening on the
boundary
to enhance privacy of the residents
this is an allocated site it's already
got outland planning permission the
applications before you today are a
natural progression from that the
proposals represent good design
that's subject to your granting planning
commission will enable construction to
start early next year
which will ultimately deliver 180 open
market homes and 45 affordable homes
we very much hope you can endorse your
office's recommendations to approve
thank you very much
thank you
mr oak thank you
our second speaker to this these two
applications is important
who's the applicant
when you settle you have three minutes
likewise thank you to address
the convention thank you very much well
good morning chair councillors um
my name is ian paulfrey i'm the head of
the land of planning protector homes and
i have the overall responsibility of
overseeing the progression of our land
interest
and uh the delivery of the two
mantelaway planning applications
we originally
looked at this site in october 2019
so that's over over two years now
with the site uh being particularly
suitable to our company profile in terms
of location since we have historically
had a strong presence
in the torridge north devon area now the
applications you see before you are very
much a team effort within the company
and they're reflective of our design
ethos in terms of adherence and massive
um priority application we had extensive
engagement with the lpa and others most
notably
the adjacent kingsley house and the town
council
we appreciate the time given by them
during the consultation periods as well
as all the
statutory consultees
who provided their responses in a timely
manner
despite the complications of cobid and
the inability to meet
face to face
the planning design process started back
in august 220
so what you see for you is in my view a
well-considered and thought-out scheme
having gone through several iterations
on layout
so as well as providing the lpa with the
credible scheme we also have to ensure
that our technical team at debauchery
homes are happy that we have a buildable
scheme and then we don't need to go back
to planning on a buildability grounds
we feel
we have taken note of the strategy
consultees and also listen to members of
the public
with most notably removal of the
secondary access to discover road
i notice also that we are including
considerable amounts of off-site highway
section 278 improvements including
pedestrian crossing
and improvements to the existing
pedestrian stroke cycle network
the application was made at the end of
april
220 one
machine
which was close to the timing update of
the outline so bearing this in mind we
would therefore be pleased to be able to
secure the delivery of the much needed
20 affordable homes as per the outline
section 106 equipment
and as a local company would like to see
that opportunity taken
uh with all this in mind we very much
hope you can endorse the playing
officer's recommendations
[Music]
thanks for your time thank you mr paul
thank you
james would like to
take a seat again
any questions on this
first application
thank you
councillor christine thank you um yes
mention was made that they came to the
bitter town council they gave a very
good
um
display of what they wanted to do and
they answered all our questions there
can i say i welcome
the improvements to the cycle network
and that is really good to hear that but
could i ask about the hedges
uh alongside mantilla wayne because
when i asked um about these at a site
visit
um devon county
said they didn't belong to them
um and i'm just wondering
are they i assume i hope they are going
to be kept and maintained because what i
don't want to see is manchester away
just the whole line of houses
lining it all the way up as you go
because the hedges at the moment are
actually quite an attractive feature um
are they going to be kept and who will
maintain them
yes thank you chad and thank you
christine yes they
the hedgerow certainly will be retained
along the frontage apart from obviously
the
small section that will need to be
removed for the creation of the access
it it actually benefits this site i
think quite a lot because you've got
quite a
large space between the edge of the
carriageway and that and the um
and the hedgerow so
sometimes obviously we find that you
need to remove quite a lot of hedgerow
to create visibility space or something
but it's not the case in this instance
so all that will be removed is literally
that
portion to create the the carriageways
coming in and that's all and then in
terms of maintenance that will be
maintained um as part of the overall
landscaping scheme as well um the
developer is committed to
maintaining that until the completion of
the development and then thereafter it
will be
handed over to a management company to
to maintain as well
i've also had confirmation from the
highways officer that
it is currently maintained by the
highways um department as well so that's
probably covered one way or another
just come back on that because
you you mentioned there is quite a wide
uh area of grass before you get to the
hedge which is quite unusual actually
and is there any scope and i'm sure
devon county gonna leap up and say no
that um
when you drive to basketball and you get
to the rounds where around about you
drive up past sainsbury's there's a
lovely avenue of trees on the side there
is there any chance of planting trees
along this area of grassland
i think that's probably one for michael
newcomer
i'm not sure you know that's allowing
this time
obviously needed to check
that it's part of the public highway of
that verge
yeah yes um i'll give you a short answer
the slightly longer answer is that
um i think mvpf has actually changed
isn't it too um to put more emphasis on
planting trees on the highway and we
haven't been to a certain degree with
them
we
certainly won't maintain them
um but there are examples
on new sites perhaps on the north level
certainly elsewhere where on the
adoption plan it wasn't slightly bizarre
because it's kind of like
red squares or circles
you know along with
where the trees are so as long as
they're intrigued pits
and um as long as we don't adopt them or
are maintained
and adopt them um
[Music]
there's a conversation to be had
right so
if for example the town council because
we've got a policy about planting trees
if we approached devon county and said
we would like to plant trees along here
that's worth following up with there's a
conversation behind yeah absolutely
and this this is definitely public land
isn't it
yeah i did double check and i i
shouldn't point out that land charges
records do come with a health warning um
the the
effectively copied from the um the
historical land charges uh maps which
look like they've been filled out by a
seven year old with the crayola so
they're not there's any depth of them
but um but as it stands at the moment it
does look like they're almost all the
land charges planets yeah
i think yeah i only say that
because we go back to the recent
application of tadworthy where you
were talking about planting trees in
people's gardens and that was a no hope
but
this i think we could actually look at
this so thank you
sorry the flip side is as an example i
think right saying that with runs with
watch
um that's where it treats
well um in highway um so
there's a conversation it's not it's not
a long strategic network
proposals and
so forth okay
can i therefore propose to accept this
right yes thank you for coming
that
thank you councillor
councillor yeah i've just got one
general observation bottom of page 107
it discusses the um education
conclusion i've never seen it anywhere
before it says the dwellings uh that
qualify which are not affordable and
have two or more bedrooms i've never
seen that before
well with under devon county council
education
contributions it just normally says per
dwelling so i wonder what the difference
was
yeah thank you guys a lot thank you
have seen it on other agreements where
there's where it's um qualifying
dwellings and then that's set out in the
um 106 in terms of what black actually
means and it's usually
um it usually excludes the affordable
values from that but
and we see it the other way as well
where it's just all dwellings really
that
this is really because it's carried over
from the original 106 back in 2018 and
that's how that was drafted and agreed
at that time so it was just carried
across from that
okay
thank you
thank you
i got a question on page 101 at the
bottom of the county council highways
there seems to be a bit of a conflict
there
about the
condition
11
4.8 for the more close c
about the fact that
refers to a football on the public
highway frontage required by this
commission
and it says there's no such requirement
none of the three plan plans approved
over the outline in the plans scheduled
on the decision not his short footwear
on the public highway frontage
and such a footwear is not part of devin
johnson's proposals
but then the next paragraph again says
this is not correct
can you just clarify that from the
please check yes certainly
in terms of the outline it it is your
opposite view that the the outgoing
commission didn't secure um that uh
provision of a cyberware across the site
frontage on west on uh montejo
the condition was in there as a
as a standard conditioner which does
usually refer to a footwear across the
footage of the site um in my view that
that was just a copy and paste on to
that um onto that decision because we
didn't have an approved plan sort of
setting
the scope of that improvement
effectively so but what we have done
obviously as as the army's officer says
that
an alternative solution has been
agreed which which you'll see in one
following presentation which um which
that that facility actually will be
delivered through the reserve matters um
approval if this members were invited
well all right james thanks for cleaning
that point
well it's been moved to approve this
application my council christie sent me
by council watson can you take the vote
please
yes thank you chair councillor
councillor brown for councillor christie
or councillor craigie
[Music]
we'll move on now to the reserve matters
application to which refers to the
eastern side of the site which has been
discussing the gender item 7g on page
115
of your agenda
[Music]
yes thank you chair uh as as today this
is a item 7g this is um uh application
one part one slash operation
twenty
so this is item uh 7g which is uh
application 1 0.23 2021 remm uh it's a
reserved matters application for access
appearance landscaping there to scale
uh pursuant to the to the outdoor
commission
uh this is relates as you say chair to
the um to the land to the east of
montana way uh as proposed it's um
uh for 225 dwellings 20 of which would
be affordable
uh also included a local area for play
and a local equipped area for play
and hovers in infrastructure
improvements um comprising two plus
stops
uh two pin crossing and widened cycleway
and footwear along alongside parentage
on on the western side of mount airway
next slide vigil
as shown here this is uh the site edge
in red wrapped around kingsley house
this is effectively the the just the
eastern part of the the wider outline
commission again forensically flat
rising up towards the north west corner
and dropped sharply away towards the
east
and dropping away sharply
beyond the northern boundary
where there's mines road and existing
dwellings
along there as well
um it's worth noting as well that the
bid 03 allocation is located to the
north of this site as well
which uh
um
the quality requires uh approximately
300 drawings on that site to the north
with open space and recreation of 2.5
hectares
next slide visual
this is part of the proposed site plan
that will split it into um into two
slides because it actually doesn't fit
on on one slide very well so
um and what we can see is the single
access point proposed onto monte away
on the site's western boundary and we've
got the main internal
road running through the centre of the
site minor roads leading off that
we've got a range of dwellings white
types and sizes and ranging between
one bedroom properties three to five
bedroom properties
a mixture of detached semi detached
small terraces and apartments
we've also got a wide range of dwelling
designs and total there's 12
different house types
or with various
uh
variations to them in terms of materials
used or hipped roofs or
um gator lanes etc
we've also got a few
three story buildings for pose for a
variety of
of heights across the site as well
the materials to be used on the
properties would be uh
render
and surrey russet's brick which is like
a red brick
and also a brunswick bath which is more
of a sand color
and then slate gray tiles and the roof
coverings
in terms of the affordable housing we've
got a mixture of social rented and
shared ownership
which are focused in three main areas of
the site and totally for a number of
four to five affordable dwellings um
representing 20 of the of the total
amount
we can also see here on the green areas
sort of running on in north south access
these are retained hedgerows
and that will have sort of formed the
part of the the site currently in terms
of the agricultural uses and this will
be
retained and strengthened
where possible because in some instances
they're they're in
quite poor condition actually now
we can also see across the northern
boundary of kingsley house there's a
tree planting proposed along
that boundary and also down part of the
um the eastern valley mr kingsley house
this is
as a dual benefit really providing
privacy for the residents of of kingsley
house
the north national autistic center
and also
that allows the dwellings to be pulled
away from that boundary somewhat as well
in terms of just having a
better relationship between the site and
its neighbouring
to the north part of the site we've got
the uh proposed lap and the leak
and um there's also a proposed fitness
trail which um
runs around runs through the
site and incorporates both that lap in
the lead with various pieces of
fixed exercise equipment and markers
along along the routes as well which
i'll come to you later in the
presentation
and next slide vision
this is the other part of the site
you can see here the main point to note
i think is that
uh previously proposed as mentioned by
um
the applicant and the agent is is that
there was previously uh uh
a secondary access proposed on to artist
um
the officer's report sets out the
reasons why that is considered not to be
deliverable and um and the applicant and
the agent both touched on that as well
effectively it would remove require the
removal of a significant amount of pedro
to either provide a northern
footwear on the northern side of the
scotland or the southern side
um
the
that would obviously have a significant
biodiversity impact and that's been
confirmed in a letter from the
applicant's ecologist and would also
impact upon the rural character of that
part of the lane as well um it is quite
a transitional area from the urban area
benefit through to the countryside
beyond and
um because of the changing levels as
we'll see on photographs later it would
require retaining walls to be introduced
in this in this part of the site which
on land which isn't controlled by the
applicant that would be controlled by
the kingsley house or or by the
commercial operators to the south
and and
and that obviously provides um a barrier
to that coming forward really
we did also consider the option of not
having the footwear on there and still
having vehicular access but
myself and the hobbies officer will
agree that that doesn't offer safe and
suitable access to the site it i mean
i've walked it a number of times and and
you know sort of taking your life in
your own hands a little bit there we go
um the dives there without a footwear
there so for those reasons it's been
removed from the scheme um the hawaii's
officer has confirmed that he has no
objection to to that
um and there's partly of compensation
for that as well we have
included a pedestrian access which will
be on the other side of kingsley house
so that will provide then a pedestrian
route for the future residents of the
site to
to leave the site and sort of access
other parts of
this road like the school down there and
also a play area etc as well so
and so it's not the case that they're
going to have to walk up to the main
vehicular access and then come back down
once they're away and then i'll start
with discovery
the other point today probably on this
side of the plan is the attenuation pond
which is over on the on the western side
there
uh the
lead local float authority have been
consulted
across the throughout the application
and including the submission of
additional information they've
confirmed they have no objection to the
proposals
next though sean
okay so this is um part of the
landscaping plan
i've got a very comprehensive plan
really for the site which uh
which introduces again sort of on the
top of the trees we've got some trees
sort of running down the main route
through there
and also a number of
as i said previously the the existing
um hedgerow boundaries that were
a result of the agricultural use will be
strengthened and they will provide
useful
back corridors and also a sort of useful
green infrastructure links throughout
the cycle sort of that one
in particular links up to the proposed
play areas
and we'll just encourage um sort of
healthier healthier feel to the
development healthy lifestyles etc
on the right hand side we've just got
artistic impression of the village
square as well which is
which you can see on that plan where the
two
large red apartment buildings are that
is they're sort of an l-shaped
configuration which will then frame uh
the village square there in that part of
the site
uh next slide usual
this is just the other part of the
landscaping plan um in relation to the
to the uh the eastern part of the site
again you can see the existing pedros
strengthened there and again
the boundary treatments around
the kingsley house development as well
as obviously the individual plots etc
which will be grass and
shrubs introduced etc as well
next slide vision
this is the the leap in the lab the two
play areas um located towards the
northern
boundary both are well within the
walking distances required by the local
plan um significantly below those
distances
and as you can see from that as proposed
there's a number of different play items
um which will obviously
assist in bringing that part of the site
forward is a usable area that would
benefit future residents of the site
and that's also banged up in the
section 106 agreement in terms of the
specification
for those two areas
the next location
so this is the open space strategy i've
just included this really because as i
mentioned there is the
the uh the exercise route or trim trail
which is shown there
in the um purple dashed line which might
be a little bit difficult to pick out
actually but um sort of goes through
oh yeah that's better thank you sean and
sort of reach through the
leap in the lap
and uh through the development as well
yeah that microphone's come off again no
i think it's because it's in the screen
when you talk i think it's made
yeah
technologies
so that that's um obviously a a
relatively cost effective way of
delivering a facility on site that
encourages healthier lifestyles and
active um sort of lifestyles for the
future residents
without the need to travel off-site or
pay a subscription to anything so
can you can you all still hear me
because i know
okay
uh okay next slide usual
so as as i um
mentioned earlier there's a number of
different host types all of which have
variations to them depending on where
effects on the site they are in terms of
materials with their hips or
or um or gable ends
and side windows etc so i don't propose
to show you all
uh all of those today because i think
there's like 13 different house types
but they are all of a similar character
so i'm just going to go through a
sort of select few of those to give you
an idea of what's proposed really so
this first one is the um is the
two-bedroom affordable dwelling
um which we have the elevations are on
the left and on the right hand side uh
a perspective image of how that's likely
to look
um it's worth noting with the affordable
dwellings that they're they're not
distinguishable from the open market
dwellings so they will be tenure blind
which is obviously positive there
um
we have um obviously quite well
proportioned um elevations as you can
see here this is the the render above
the brick plinth
and as i said the variations to that in
terms of the the hit or the gamer lens
depending on where on the side they are
um it's weird things as well the
affordable dwellings exceed
all of the um the space damage which is
set out in the in the 106 as well next
likely sean
these are the affordable apartments
these will be located in the south
western corner of the site
and this is really so that we can
deliver the one bedroom apartments to
provide a broad range of of housing
options
for persons who are unable to access
open market properties
and this is in accordance again with the
106 in terms of the mix of one two three
and four bed affordable affordable
properties
and this this proposed building would
would accommodate two apartments per
floor
which would be six in total um for for
that building
next lively sean
this is the four bears open market
dwelling and again the
perspective image of that on the right
hand side
next slide please
three bed
open market dwelling
these are um
the
[Music]
dwellings that would be located on the
on the corners of the streets and that
urban design feature of helping you turn
the corner in terms of
having a dual dual aspect
next slide please
uh these are the split level dwellings
the three three bedroom open market
drive-ins um
as i mentioned earlier in the
presentation the the parts of the site
in in the western
western part does start to drop away
quite quickly and so this is a design
solution for that in terms of having a
split level property which
which takes account of the natural
deformity of the site really so i just
think it's useful to
to know that the development does um
take advantage of the natural topography
rather than trying to re-level
everything and sort of rather than
delivering flat props there so
next slide please
uh these are the open market apartments
so you i mentioned earlier this time
square these these are the outshaped
configuration apartments that would um
flank that time square again
it's
positive in urban design terms to
enclose that space um
[Music]
and
again you can see the hip throughs there
which will reduce the the mass skin bulk
as well with those
next slide
please these are just some of the street
scenes just to show the variety across
the site in terms of
a mixture of
uh two-story and three-story buildings i
think there's only
12 different dwellings that are
three-story i think across the whole
site and imagery those are obviously
two-story but you can see there there
will be some some good varieties to
avoid um sort of monotonous frontages
along along the streets on the
development
next slide please
and again some further street scenes
there
uh
again just showing how that would aim in
development
looks like there's the third street
scenes there
this is the highways infrastructure
that's proposed so um
they're outlined in
into the turquoise you have the the edge
of the access that will be created onto
mantei away
and that again confirms that there's
it's not necessary to remove
a significant amount of hedgerow it
would just be the amount required to
form the access itself
now we've got a two pin crossing
proposed just to the
south of the access
and we've also got two proposed bus
stops there as well
and then the existing cycleway and
footwear on on the western side of monte
away which is
the prop is quite variable along its
length but generally about one meter in
width that would be
wide into three meters across the whole
of the frontage of the sidebar
and as recommended there's a condition
to
secure all of those works which will
also be delivered through the section
278 highways process
and the condition requires those to be
delivered prior to the occupation of any
dwelling on the site as well so
that does just come forward quite early
in development
next slide please
uh just some photographs now that we
have seen on on the members site visit
top left is
along the um boundary of
um
kingsley house there
sorry it's not it's across the top of
the northern boundary of the site there
so on the left-hand side of those for
the existing dwellings that are located
on on mines road beyond to the north of
the site
on the bottom left that is the northern
boundary of kingsley house looking
across that to the to the um to the east
top centre we have existing gated gated
access onto our stock road and that's
the commercial
uses beyond that's the location where
the pedestrian access would be
would be proposed
and then we have uh bottom center is the
eastern boundary
in kingsley house
and on the right we've got a photograph
just looking south back across the
kingsley house back across the site
next slide please
okay so this is just some photographs
here top left is
uh albert scott road this is taken from
outside kingsley so you can see how the
road starts to narrow at that point
the bottom left is again albert scott
road with the grounds kingsley house on
the left-hand side and you can see
that the difference is levels really
between the carriageway and kingsley
house grounds which would necessitate
some quite substantial um
retaining walls on online that's not
going to be owned by the applicant now
top center um we have the that on the
right hand side is the the
the access would be created
and bottom center we have the eastern
part of the site where you can see the
land falling away there
and then on the right hand side
this is the existing cycleway footwear
which is proposed to be wide into three
meters um as i said
that's currently is generally about one
meter across its length and that will be
widened across the hole in the frontage
of the site
next slide please
these are just some longer distance
photographs from the landscape and
visual
assessment
the top one is
from gamiton and southeast of the site
and site shown there in that orange
orangey red color
and at the bottom we have a
photograph from albany stock road from
further out and to the east of the site
next slide please
and then uh gamington road um south of
the site is the top photograph and then
from mines road northwestern sites is
the bottom coast graph
looks like this
[Music]
the top photograph here is from ball
hill uh on southpop which is north of
the site
and the bottom photograph is probably
laying in eastleigh which is northeast
of the site
next slide please
okay the material considerations are the
principle of development design
character and appearance green
infrastructure residential humanity
biodiversity housing mix
highways empowerment surface water
drainage
principle of development is established
by the previously granted outline
commission and also the variations of
that which was a resolution to grants
has just been
[Music]
broad range of housing options across
the site has proposed which will
assist in um particularly in terms of
the affordable housing in
business who are unable to access open
market housing options
we've also got a good degree of variety
across the site because of that range of
housing in terms of different materials
and different place types etc
uh associated benefits as well in terms
of the construction phase and the
economic benefits associated with that
we're delivering biodiversity net gain
across the site as well in terms of the
creation of significant numbers of new
development hedge funds and native
pedros and also the limited loss of
existing headquarters as well
um surface and surface water and power
water will be appropriately managed
and we've got a limited number of
objections and jobs of which did focus
on the
stock road access which has now been
removed from the scheme
we've also got as
christie mentioned the the support of
the town council for the development
and for those reasons it's your office's
view that the
the proposal is acceptable and it's
definitely recommend that reserve
master's approval be granted
subject to the conditions set out
and also an additional condition
just to cover
external lighting on the footpaths
throughout the site um we've got an
approved drawing which covers all of the
main street lighting on the
um major roads throughout the site but
there's obviously a number of footpaths
throughout the site as well which don't
which obviously give a positive in terms
of permeability throughout the site but
they will need
um to be lit and so it's recommended
that the condition
um
be added just in terms of
the specification and delivery of that
writing some videos it would be sort of
low-level bollard lighting really and if
members are happy with that to delegate
the world into offices i can
draft something and send that to the
chair and the vice chair um
okay so that's it for me thank you if
you have any questions
thank you thank you james for that
in-depth presentation
councillor christian
yeah um
again we had this presentation we were
very impressed with the kind of jogging
route within the estate that was a new
one i asked it was very good um can i
ask one thing
there's a huge number of documents
associated with this actually over 400
i haven't read them all
[Music]
but going through is there any um is
there any survey of the site being done
in terms of geology because this was an
ex-mining area and every other
application we've had at 1908 it's had a
geological
survey
yeah thank you thank now
guys christy yes that was part of the
outline um application back in 2017 just
to ensure that so that effectively set
the developable area um and then that
also tied in with the condition
regarding um contamination as well
because
councillor craigie
um i'd like to speak on behalf of the
people into the water and also um
councillor mckenzie because he would
have liked to have been here to speak
with that potential
we've already got two large estates that
go off mantellive
and there's hundreds of homes up there
now in this state where councilmember
kennedy is there was an accident in the
entranceway okay
after two hours
nobody can get in or out of that state
no one can go to work and a lot of care
workers live up there and everybody has
to go by car
because there's only a bunch every half
hour and you know it only goes one way
um so
not only were all the lives the people
were engaging there's no ambulances no
fire engines could get into that space
and nobody would go to work
or get home from work and there was
nowhere to park they came home there was
no way to go home
they
so
we feel quite strongly about this there
should be two entrances to the escape
we understand the problems well with
scott rowley and our own country name
and we know we've been playing about
the entrance but we really feel quite
strongly that there should be another
entrance
we can't keep on repeating the same
mistakes
it's like saying well you know
it's not work twice but let's keep on
trying this and see if it does work one
of these times it's gonna be a really
serious problem
and no ambulance or no time
uh engine can get through to the estate
so
that's our main complaint
that the the second one is
directed to the council and the planning
department
is
the section 106 money is going to waste
the water and not east the water
it's not as if eastern water is one of
the most deprived parts of the torres
it has a lot of family we have a lot of
council you know social housing
and yet the section 106 money for the
player equipment is going to the skate
park
barely any of our children get down to
you because of the major votes
across to get there
and we have got desperate need
to prepare for events in east water
and we haven't made any civil at all so
two little things
i'm trying to go on but we really
[Music]
feel incredibly strongly about this
[Music]
and deal with the highways related first
point if that's okay
in terms of the section 106 the
original um
the original 106 is actually original
outline had a contribution at 75 000 for
the skate park
that the skate park has been delivered
obviously and so in your office's view
that that isn't actually a still
compliant um
uh contribution anymore because it's
already been delivered so there's no
need for that contribution so
what what is proposed in the in the 106
is to actually use that 75 000 instead
for highway improvement works within the
vicinity of development so that would
that and that's obviously quite a broad
open um uh
position really in terms of i know i did
have some contact with council mackenzie
and he suggested that it could be used
for um traffic lights at the bottom of
mount airy away with basketball rovers
an issue but i mean it is quite open
ended it would need some work with the
highways
team in terms of what that would be
spent on but that that does have that
possibility there and that would be
obviously related to east of the water
because it's within the vicinity of the
development
and the the other contributions as well
do do relate to um the developments
itself and would be spent within east of
the water i mean it's
they always almost have to be really
because to pass the sale test they have
to be related directly to the
development and that means that you end
up sort of spending them within
relative close proximity to the site
anyway so
um hopefully that does provide you with
something so james could i could i
understand that you consult with the
district councillors
at eastwater on that 75 000 pound
reallocation please yes i have done so
yes no not just put it to a highway
and rather you discussed it with the
three district councils now
[Music]
craig is raised the same issue because i
noticed you stopping up the gateway into
alba district road and i made it now
emergency vehicle access only into all
the district rule that could have been
provided here
okay
um
and i do i do think it is a serious
admission that there's only one way in
and out of the estate for vehicles yeah
because
councilman craig has
mentioned one issue that happened
already over there
and the same thing happened at gentle
hill a big development there there was
originally no access on because you
remember into development then
an access has been
permitted there now which gives which
we'll give two ways in and out so for
crossing and navy rule as well and i
think because it's a very large
development as
we really ought to be looking at a
second even if it's only for emergency
vehicles
okay can i ask them my particular name
on that yeah
[Music]
them um rather than the lights you can
um you can just do row closure on one of
the accesses
um but it is a preference um there is
alternative accesses here for
pedestrians
[Music]
the applicant did cite a number of
examples where
um
similar size developments in the area
have actually got single access i know
we can't have precedent planning
[Music]
this is the first time anyone's ever
said he can't hear me
um so from a highway point of view i
tell complete sympathy for the two
councillors have made the
raising concerns
um
and from a highway point of view it
actually makes it easier if you do have
two entrances when it comes to say
resurfacing you know you do have a road
closure and you want access over them
rather than have to do it on the traffic
lights with one access
what i would say is it but it is a
preference that we have um there is a
secondary access for pedestrians the
south of the site um the applicant did
cite a number of examples in the area
and in what i can think of in the wider
area where there is single access for
similar size prop
single-sized estates
and i know we can't have
preceding planning but we should have
consistency
um
and on that basis i think bearing in
mind relatively random
random and rare events
i think we will struggle to defend that
appeal if um we recommend refusable i
understand what you're saying about
secondary access but the the secondary
axis is that i can think of our states
have invariably got
it won't stop pedestrians using them
and then we come back to the original
problem where um vehicles wouldn't be
able to filter through emergency access
is because for example the bollards
pedestrians would we've got to square
one with regards to what we're going to
do about footwear on over the spot roads
um and people walk around the district
world now anyway but would be incredible
absolutely but a would be increasing the
numbers and being like james said i'm
sure you've been there yourself you do
think your life in your own hands and as
you say michael there is a pedestrian
access onto that roundabout on that
corner correct yes to the south
side that's right yeah so it does
provide a reasonably um straightforward
route for pedestrians the other thing
that i think somebody else has said
already but the represents
representations i received from the
members of the public
um was included via the county
councillor were predominantly about
people who live on norfolk this got road
already complaining about
a the rat what they referred to as rat
running and i was surprised when i was
on site how many large vehicles did you
see
i mean they're not one a minute but
they're they're more frequently think
um and their concerns were that this
would increase the number of people that
running um so like i said that that's
what representations i've seen you know
i said i think i've started out by
saying if we went to appeal because i
think we struggle
so completely
mention of consistency
i do agree in planning we need to a
degree consistency but
not consistency
as councillor craig is making the same
mistake over and over again when there's
a chance sure particularly particularly
on this site
to have an emergency access
yeah the vehicles
i i would add as well i'm sorry
say this very quickly then please um the
other thing i want to say is i have sat
and i was in front in front of the qc
but i have set an appeal
locally where um this
i think we're talking about 270
dwellings um and
this exact argument was put forward
and it didn't get a lot of traction with
the um with the uh and this wasn't the
only reason in fact i think that i
always actually recommend approval but
this is one of the um
uh arguments that were put forward by
the objectives who examined who are
doing against the development and didn't
get a lot of traction with um the
inspector at the time sorry
[Music]
and it's a nice open highway and i've
seen and some of the little
bits of the estate actually go back
towards
anterior way just open one of those
sure
we you appreciate we're constantine's
presence so we
[Music]
you do make recommendations on planning
applications on that specifically online
so but if the plan will go to your
confidence
with our agreement and our understanding
then we can look at that okay okay
we're not very happy that
[Music]
yeah
our first point is when we saw them back
to james when we saw around the slides
of the different sort of houses have
anything else that's got garages at all
but they didn't i didn't pick any
garages
again
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ones that haven't as well they're posing
um
positive element a separate cycle store
with an on plot as well so that they've
still got so if they've got garage then
the assumption is that they would
see could be used for um storage for the
[Music]
they say
that there was a condition mentioned in
the original committee report from the
outline
um but it was not included in the actual
decision notice
so
should that be included on page 135
under condition number eight otherwise
it's not going to be included again
yes uh that that wasn't i've spoken to
the senior historic environment officer
about about that issue it wasn't
included on the first one but i think in
my view we're not
we don't have the ability to add
condition to get onto it because what
we're looking at is just the three on
the outline anyway
anyway
it's just looking at the three
variations of the world into those
conditions so
it's not a situation where
the development's materially changing
and we can look to add other um
conditions to mitigate a particular
impact um because it literally is that
that sort of exercise barrier that we're
doing really so
in your office's view it wasn't possible
to to include that again on anyone
okay
council christian and councilman
well yes um
would like to propose it but um
councillor craig has raised a very good
point um the one you mentioned in
londonderry especially
i got that
25 years there 30 years ago we put that
in place i don't think it's ever been
opened actually but it is there and it
was designed to stop rap running
down north down road and up through the
state i can't see rat running occurring
on this estate because it doesn't
actually
you wouldn't knit through to get
anywhere else
but
i realized we can't discuss it today in
a sense because
it's not part of the planning
application but
would it be possible would demonstrate
homes have been very accommodating up
until now uh come to the town council
they took our ideas on board have been
very accommodating
could i ask could they
would they go back and discuss with
highways the possibility of an emergency
access somewhere i'm not sure where i'm
not sure it should come out on manteo
away because
that goes back to the hedge line and
everything else um
if if it's possible that they go back
bearing in mind that council craving has
raised
quite a serious issue i think
thank you thank you man
i think i think from an opposite volume
i do know this sort of concerns
regarding that that access and and and
uh obviously very bad cases
but i think that
as michael said as well the point
of that we're looking at is is this
proposal acceptable or not really rather
than being able to um
work with other amendments so i mean if
obviously if committee reminded to
resolve the grant approval today then
that would fix this this layout in this
development so i think it's not
something that we could require the
applicant to do um
although
in future they may wish to look at that
as a variation james i think i accept
that i accept that but
[Music]
we approved the planning problems which
had one way working at the top end of
that
into um atlantic way that's been changed
now
through discussions with our planning
offices under development
so i mean the point of cancer crystal
rays is
i would expect behind the scene not
behind the scenes but i would expect
that you have that discussion anyway
[Music]
yeah i mean we could say that we can
certainly do that i just think vendors
need to be aware that obviously it would
give them an implementable scheme
in terms of an approval today that they
could continue with an implementation
thank you chair
if i can just come back on that um that
very particular point um different
through tabworth videos
if we were looking at an emergency
secondary layout or access to this
layout it would be a fundamental change
layout and i think that's the difference
between this scheme and some
fundamentals today and how we don't
really tag one of it which didn't
require that fundamental change the
layout
thank you thank you councilman
[Music]
um
just like it's touching the construction
management plan
from w homes obviously the increased
site movement the heavy vehicles that
are coming in
using access from our district roads um
i'd like to obviously comment from
highways if you could this is going to
be increased traffic coming in as it's
been
actually addressed because we've got a
backlog of traffic coming through
obviously aware of baby road at the
moment the construction traffic coming
in and the lorry is backing up you
probably get six seven eight glorious at
the time back in that because you had a
moment being a country cancer for that
area we've got a lot of problems here a
minute so i'm trying to address my
highways officer trying to alleviate a
problem from the residents there on a
daily basis
so obviously it's going to be a lot of
increased traffic has the construction
management plan have been you know being
addressed properly there because it's a
narrow part of the road and we're going
to get heavy vehicles
using it daily
here sorry think i called he said
somebody's deciding we've got an angle
grinder um
yeah so effective what we say is the
construction manager and he's making
sure the routine comes off for example
from the 839 off wesley junction and
around yeah i mean we can we can include
that
[Music]
okay and just mention a couple of things
in in the old development plan for play
areas and play equipment it used to
specify on sites exactly what should
happen now
that's gone now with the plan that we
deal with now and what we look at now is
green space
percentage of green space well
every little
verge every little
triangle all that adds up
and say well it's actually supplying
more green space than the clown would
ask for but it's scattered about
what i am very disappointed again with
this is the play provision on this site
we've got a leap and a lap which
they're all right as far as goal but
again there's no mugger here and i don't
think there's any on any of you it's new
estates always the water there's no
playing fields at all i know we've got
polly field
which not near this
and i'm disappointed that we keep having
these presentations and large sites that
don't address the issue of proper
pitches for youngsters to play
football or whatever it might be
and
then as council chris mentioned i like
the idea of the track going all around
the job is traveling
that's brilliant
but we've missed the boat somewhere with
our local plan in taking out
specifications that used to be
members will remember if it was for 200
dwellings you have to provide xyz if it
was a hundred twelvings you had to
provide this that's all done and all we
talk about is green space now
which doesn't address for me play
provision properly so side support
forward as this has
been just a couple of small player
so-called play areas which
youngsters can't really play much on
them
so i'll make that quick the other thing
again i always mentioned there are no
bungalows on this
there's 225 dwellings here none of them
abundance
small bundles
terrorist bumblebees would have been
ideal from here like there are existing
many supports
veteran terrorist bombers you'd sell
that hotcakes
and people could dance
mentioning that and nationally it's
talked about
elderly people who want to downsize from
family service languages
one of those little ways to go but never
you didn't seem to get many put on these
sites so that's
that is a
negative aspect of this for me
i'm very pleased to see this 45
affordable over
i
[Music]
[Music]
perhaps talk to david county about this
emergency accident it may not be
possible but i think we need to flag it
up at this stage rather than
just nod it through i i say not it
through but
if they get their planning pollution
they can go ahead on this basis we all
know that but as i say temperature home
has been very accommodating and i think
they may find it's not impossible but i
think we ought to leave that avenue open
and say yes can they actually have a
talk with them county about this
i mean if the three eastward district
councils are happy there's 75 000 pounds
of section 106 money
which
but the case also has discussed that
with the world members i'm just looking
at the email now um so they were aware
of that 75 000 pounds and that wasn't
into the infrastructure i i know so i'm
calling that
christian figure mentions that plans can
you see
[Music]
council crystal councillor watson's
second minute i'd just like to mention
in the
conditions the recommendation
and the conditions
at five where it mentions two bus stops
on mountie away i think we should add in
there and shelters
i think there should be much shelters
provided there as well
um
and i'll take it the two compresses now
i like control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
an additional nine condition to do with
lighting with the foot plus
the old level lighting that was
mentioned
so that would be uh
condition
and the bus
shelters there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's eight four one against jeff
thank you standard thank you james
which is on page 140 of your agenda
will give this presentation
thank you tracy
thank you chair can everyone hear me
okay yeah okay
[Music]
okay so this is item 7h it's application
1-0987
2021 full application
so this is a retrospective application
for a temporary covered seating canopy
so the application is the four members
due to tourist district council
retaining an interest in the land
um just in terms of global updates um
since the public vision of the report
there has been one further
representation received of support
um this comments during the copy times
the canopy is a wonderful addition
customers can use the coffee shop and
feel much safer sat outside and some
shelters are provided from the elements
and it's very attractive and done and
enhanced the key
so going on to the location plan sensors
education plan and site plan
as you'll see on the location plan the
area of the canopy is in outlined in red
the application site is located in the
prominent location on benefit key
the application site comprises of a hard
surface paved area immediately to the
front which will deteriorate
22 the key is a three-story terraced
building the ground floor of the
building is currently used as a
restaurant slash cafe
called key 22. next slide please
this is an aerial image showing the
context of the key location the site is
indicated with a little red blob
um that you can see
which i'm sure members are very familiar
with the central location
within the key of biddeford
um just to sort of point out to members
the site is within a different
conservation area and the building
printed with he is a great
building
so moving on to a photo of the existing
site clearly this is a retrospective
application so i have used google earth
in which um that was taken in 2018
to show members the sort of existing
site before the structure was erected
as members can see historically the
site has always been used for outside
seating area on the hardstanding area to
allow customers to
consume food and drink outside
so next slide so this is just very
quickly the existing elevations so it
shows the front of the key22 and the two
side elevations again on those plans are
our annotated table and chairs to show
historically this has always been used
for customers to consume food and drink
next slide so this is moving on to the
proposal so the proposal is for a
temporary covered seating area to be
used in association
with the restaurants from cafe p22
the applicant is seeking a temporary
permission to allow the structure
retained for three year period
so the proposed elevations that they can
appear erected as you can see to the
front of the building on the paved area
but not physically attached to the
building
so the plant of the left is the front
elevation of key 22 showing that
structure to the front elevation
and then second to the north and south
elevations the side elevations of the
structure
[Music]
the next slide so this is some proposed
elevations with measurements annotated
on
so the campaign measures 7.8 meters by
5.3 meters of a maximum height of 3.1
meters
the structure is an open timber frame
structure with nine timber columns
supports the steel shoes
bulging to the ground the roof is formed
of a perspective roof panel
the supporting statement advises the
canopy was erected to allow the
applicants to continue to trade with the
kobe 19 pandemic
the existing indoor area was too small
to accommodate customers an idea to
social distancing rules within their
premises
um as on the 11th of october 2021 the
applicant's house said the interior cafe
has now been reopened
however there are um only 23 covers
inside where previously there are 39
covers table and chairs have been
removed to allow a greater distance
between customers
the applicant has advised that indoor
not financially sustainable the outdoor
seating area allows the applicant to
accommodate more covers in all weather
while their customers seem to prefer
which is obviously much more safer
environment for them
so next slide this is a roof plan of the
canopy structure with the guttering
annotated on the plan to either side of
the structure
[Music]
um as this is a retrospective
application i can show you a few slides
of construction institute um see the
first slide and demonstrate to the front
elevation of the canopy
um as members can see the canopy is an
open timber frame nine columns
and the steel shoes which are bolted to
the ground
and the roof is constructed from perspex
as some can see the guttering to either
side of the canopy
another photo next slide is slightly
taken further back
and then the next slide is the solid
elevation sudden elevation looking onto
the canopy
and the next slide is the normal
elevation
and then a photo taken from inside the
canopy just to allow members to
understand how the account is
constructed
and the next slide is a couple of photos
just from viewpoints from the context of
the key just walking up to the key just
to show members
in the context of the other buildings
surrounding
key22
[Music]
so moving on to the planning
considerations the application site is
located in the town centre of biddeford
the planning use of the building is not
changing so there is no loss to retail
liability as a result of the proposal in
fact the outdoor seating area is
complete
is considered to improve the economic
viability of the business and facilities
available in the town centre the
proposal would therefore generate
economic and social benefits
impact on heritage assets as advised to
members the proposal is within the
biddeford conservation area and the
building is a great tool list of
buildings part of the terrace of listed
buildings known as prospect place
as members i'm sure have read the
council's conservation officer has been
consulted on this proposal
just kind of give you a little bit of a
summary
of the conservation officer's comments i
think this is quite key to this
consideration of the application
the conservation has officer house says
the proposed campaign is considered to
be overly large in this location and
visually dominates the terrorists of
buildings known as prospect place
the materials are modern and do not
reflect the character of the terrorists
of the wider conservation area
the proposal is considered to harm the
setting with the list of building and
was also visually intrusive within the
conservation area
the impact of the conservation area
reviews along with key are harmful and
failed to preserve the character of the
area
so in terms of impact on amenity the
council's environmental protection team
have been consulted and they do not
consider the daytime use of the
structure result in significant harm to
any nearby residential amenities and
then for handling objections
the environmental protection team
recommends the imposition of a condition
restricting hours of use between 10
o'clock and 1700 hours
moving on to highways the highway
authority has been consulted and
confirmed the canopy is not located on
public highway proposal does not
interfere with use of the public highway
and does obviously even severe impacts
in terms of congestion or delay and
therefore they have no highway objection
so federal skin drainage the site is
located within a critical drainage area
and we're all clustering free
a critical drainage statement has been
submitted which concludes the canopy is
located over an existing car surface
area the amount of water runoff
generated
negligible the canopy roof has been
designed for pitch to allow to run off
it is reasonable to consider
not materially result in an increase in
surface water and given the development
for an open-sided canopy over existing
outdoor paved area to the likely
development would impede the flow of
blood waters will result in increased
risk to the public ecology a wildlife
tribunalist has been submitted and there
has been no effect on protected species
as a result of the proposal
so planning balance in conclusion
your officer can understand why the
applicant has erected a robust structure
resulting in the space being used at all
times particularly with adverse weather
conditions there is no doubt that the
canopy has economic and social benefits
however these economic and social
benefits must be way against the impact
of the development upon the listed
building which is the host building and
the grey to listed terrorists and the
designated conservation area
the proposal is considered to harm the
setting of the listed terrorists and is
also visually intrusive within the
conservation area
while there may be economic benefits
associated with proposal this is not a
significant magnitude to outweigh the
harm causing
appearance of the setting of the listed
building and the conservation area
your offices are sympathetic to the
destruction caused by kobe 19 pandemic
it is therefore proposed in your report
and 12 months temporary commission will
strike an appropriate balance
between removing the candidate and
allowing the applicants a reasonable
time to make future arrangements
for these reasons approval is
recommended for this application subject
to conditions that are set up in my
report to
allow a one-year commission and for the
kind of control will be used between
time and fight
thank you
thank you tracy
for the presentation
we've got two speakers for this
application
and if they come up to the microphone
please and the first speaker is nikki
buckley
um
sorry jenny carling is down first
who's an applicant followed by nikki
and once you've settled
you have three minutes to address the
committee thank you
good morning chair and councillors
i'm jenny cowley one of the partners at
key 22.
firstly can you all believe that as a
young business we've got to this point
through pandemic
with many businesses and hospitality
forced to create new ideas all thinking
our feet just to survive in the current
climate
both nikki and i wanted to create a very
safe environment for all our customers
staff and ourselves by way of our
covered seating area and to remain
solvent
we are eternally grateful to our council
for the grants that we were given which
allowed us to continue to trade through
the pandemic and allow our canopy to be
built
our prime minister
has continually endorsed outside seating
and continues to do so as a staffer
option
we feel we have acted responsibly with
the creating of the canopy
and to enable a safe outside environment
in all weathers
one month ago as tracy has said we
opened our internal seating area but
there is still a very high percentage of
customers still preferring to sit
outside
our internal seating capacity in cafe
has been considerably reduced by 40
because of the pandemic
our business would be unviable without
the canopy as internally we've had
distance tables
north devon has a high percentage of an
aging population
and it is imperative to keep people safe
by providing covered outside seating for
all weathers
not putting further pressures on our
wonderful nhs
we have just managed to get business
viable again this is why we put in an
application for a three-year term
however we understand the council are
suggesting a recommended approval for
just the one year
bearing in mind with the rise of covered
in cases once again
we respectfully ask our council to
reconsider a granting period of at least
two years to enable our business to meet
its final obligations
we have given consideration to the
objection comments of our neighbors and
it is our intention to make some changes
to appease the situation
so that we might all may continue to
trade along with each other successfully
we are a democracy and remarkably our
number of supporters being 229
totally outweighs those objective just
15.
this itself speaks volumes of public
support in the town
we would finally like to finish by
saying the two most important things
surely coming out of this pandemic
is to keep local business thriving in
the town and our populations safe
and this is exactly what we feel our
canopy offers
thank you for listening thank you
thank you
our next speaker
is uh
and when you're settled again you have
three minutes have you to address the
committee
good morning
after giving careful consideration to
the canopy in contrary to the release of
some of the objectives we confirmed that
we had sought advice on the onset from
the planning department
discussions were also held with our
immediate neighbours and the steward of
the british trust
once restrictions were lifted in april
21 an outside city was allowed the
canopy was erected within our pavement
advancements area constructed
sustainably from wood and
semi-transparent roof to protect from
the direct sunlight
we thought the wooden frame would sit
well within the trees which lie on the
pavement
we would like to mention that the canopy
is not attached to the building when we
stand
two members of the british fire service
who have made a site visit to look at
the access to the building above and
adjacent to the canopy verbally they
confirmed there were no issues with the
access at all
we would also like to clarify that we
haven't restricted the flow of the
pavement and that the chain has been
erected by our neighbour
we've touched on the aging population
however we must all acknowledge the
increase in mental health related issues
to include anxiety and loneliness
jenny and i witnessed this first round
while serving as a takeaway during a
very challenging period from us all
we wholeheartedly believe that the
a candidate area to benefit those in
need of safe social interaction
our ethos at p22 is to balance our
impact on the environment by sorting our
produce locally this not only supports
local traders but it reduces food miles
and we reuse and recycle to an optimum
level which is a direct cost to the
business
we must meet the needs of the present
without compromising any future
generations
we advocate the local independent
businesses and there is a lovely
supporting network between us all and we
think you will agree that we should be
very proud of what biddeford has to
offer
we do provide employment to local people
of a varied age and thankfully have been
able to retain more our team is now back
settled into regular shifts
as a result of pivoting the business as
necessary through this global pandemic
thankfully we are now back on track and
this has been achieved with commitment
and relief
and to summarize we appreciate the 12
months temporary approval however we
appeal to you all today to rethink if
you personally believe we will be
covered free in 12 months
and perhaps you would consider meeting
our compromise request of 24 months to
grant us security and a peace of mind to
plan secure future for the business and
for the staff and thank you to
[Music]
counselor
[Music]
thank you chair i have a statement to be
read from the council bush leader
members
i am a bitty food north board member for
town and district councils the town
council voted to support this
application and i wish to give my
support together as planner meetings
i am in the town most days and use a
variety of coffee shops on a regular
basis key22 being one of them
the sheltered area has been a very
welcome addition during the cold week
period indeed myself and many others
still prefer to sit outdoors where there
is ample ventilation
other than two rival cafes i have not
had one person complain about the killer
canopy
quite the opposite in fact as many
people comment that enhances the street
scene giving it a more continental feel
the last 18 months has been very hard on
everyone so when we see a local business
doing exactly what the government
advised the district council should also
be supportive so i respectfully ask that
members approve this application council
of russia
thank you sean
now bringing council
but not thank you mr um before i start
that mr just like to add that i said
we're clearing open minds because when i
was mayor of benefit i had a pleasure
opening this business up
and see the progression going through
and i use all the eateries in benefit so
i have no preference to
what's your one business day okay but
i'll move straight in i would like to
propose that we grant this application
we accept this you know for grant with
the stipulation of a 24 month
period because given occurring we're not
at a pandemic and i can't say it's been
expanded any any time soon to be honest
i wish we were but we're not and to
support any local business within the
town i think that you know is the dues
of any local authority and i am one of
the ward members also along with cancer
bushby and council christie but i can't
speak with cancer christie but i don't
know why i say
i'm in support of this business
with a street scene to me
it works within billet uh benefit if you
look on a key and you've got that the
lundy view building on the key which
hasn't been mentioned that to me is an
eyesore and that does not fit into
conservation abilities
to me that bonus will be leveled we
should put something decent in there get
rid of that is that to your opponent
this structure isn't important there's
temporary structure
there's no historic thing underneath the
footpath
it's normal concrete blocks
big pavement slabs they can easily be
removed and replaced
so as we go back inside there yeah can
we go back right there perfect okay
good structure there to me obstructions
to the pedestrians there would be the
cars that are parked there which is not
relevant to this business it's another
business i'm not trying to harm
businesses
but to me when you're walking across
there and
any disabled etc it's huge white paper
what isn't shown pavement which is
adjacent to this which would be highways
pavement going across which is why
pavement or seating area also outside of
this
you know which ample
room would be able to move along the key
to me it's not affecting the structural
integrity of that building it's not
attached to a building it needs to be
solid focus to the ground it's obviously
the windows to come in it's quite windy
avenue going along there to me it's
absolutely perfect for the town and
anything we get support business and we
wonder why some of these characters
wonder why we've ever got the
regeneration bit of business let's think
outside the box and actually support new
ideas coming forward i'm pretty sure in
the future we might actually get
regeneration bits coming forward for us
so
grant
approval with the two years minimum 24
months to help his business foreign
[Music]
it's a wonderful thing actually and
people love to sit on the key
and benefit is a wonderful place but the
one we can't guarantee is the weather
and we if we've got tourists we've got
to offer something from the tourism
and this is a lovely site we've got a
lovely view of the moonlight
and and as
we've got said we're not out of code
for a long time so let's maybe even at
least twenty for one month
thank you
council christian
yeah i'm gonna pose us um
i better explain from start i've had
clearance from the solicitor about this
because
um over the last year i've been chairman
of the british trust
and you've already heard the british
trust in the properties um
i'm currently our chairman has just
moved i'm currently acting chairman as
well in a way
i am allowed to speak though um
firstly i have to point out this is a
retrospective application i don't like
those for a start
mention was made that biddeford town
council voted for it there were six
councils on the planning committee um
when this came to the vote uh
only three well three people abstained
and boat was 2-1 hardly overwhelming
um now this canopy it was actually put
up under covered regulations and code
regulations said and the prime minister
said that you can put up temporary
moveable shelters
if you go to basketball you've seen the
old bus station it's got those shelters
this one
it's well what they've done is they've
taken up the pavilions they've cemented
in their columns they've bolted them
down it's a permanent structure and it
was done under regulations which said
you shouldn't do it
um
they've actually
privatized public land
with the torridge
uh i know the conservation officers
report and
i've realized that you know beauty is in
the eye of the beholder
personally i think that looks pretty
cheap compared to the the buildings
behind it
uh falsely and this is where
obviously the british trust were
involved and they bolted this onto our
building without any
say so at all i heard the applicants say
they've been discussions in the british
trust uh no they haven't um
the british trust actually had to
instruct them to remove it from our
building being bolted on without any
permission at all
we have a problem in the we own
all three shops along this section
and the shop next door the tenant
has put in very serious complaints about
this
uh he's lost business and he's now
chained it off to keep them spreading
over
we have tenants above directly above
this
shelter
who cannot now
get to sleep until one o'clock in the
morning because this has become a magnet
for late night drinkers and revelers
they sit under the shelter and it goes
on shouting and so until one o'clock in
the morning
and our tenants are really upset they're
an elderly couple
and the thing that i think really upsets
me is everyone else has followed the
rules
this shop hasn't and given who one of
the owners is they know the rules
and it really is
very upsetting they haven't followed it
and uh i do notice
i i did ask how much i were paying for
this
and tori is going to have to look at it
very very seriously
because they've got a new shop basically
and the other thing is
although tori is saying we own it i
understand it's not registered
um
so i'm not quite certain now we're
charging anyone rent but there
uh but i'm going to oppose it on those
grounds
thank you councillor christine
councillor
um yeah i've got great sympathy videos
i'm tall at the moment which way i'm
going to vote um in their design and
access statements and i quote
my client would like to keep it as a
permanent structure ideally but
understand that it's unlikely the local
authority will accept this at this stage
so i think they are looking into the
future to keep it as a permanent one
thing i don't understand is um
under their license and agreement or any
licensing agreement i understood that
all the
furniture had to be removed every night
and they
bolted down those picnic tables
and i think one of the speakers said
that they've got lots of tables and
chairs that they don't use anymore
inside so my question is why didn't they
bring why don't they bring those out and
take them in
every night and then you could get rid
of those bulges then so many people
wouldn't
their night times i mean there's other
cafes along the front that have to take
in their tables and chairs every night
so i'm just wondering why they haven't
done the same
and of course some of the cafes on the
front haven't got that kind of space
outside
[Music]
i'm going to support the proposal that
they get 24 months temporary
use of this canopy there
i hear what's been said i read all the
reports in here
and i do think they've made their best
efforts as far as
having to reduce the numbers inside
their cattle because of the
dreaded virus
and safely space people out in there
which is obviously affecting the
viability of the business i want to
support all the businesses of the town
and the district as best i can and
through the planning process
the economy is one of the three
key things that we should be looking to
support
so
having heard what's been said if there's
a problem
in the nighttime with people
congregating under that the owners have
heard what's been said about possibly
replacing the voted down picnic tables
movable tables
maybe they'll say that but the wider
issue of the nighttime time economy
is more than just
22 the key i can be sure
um
yeah we're talking about one step
further then if that
on their licensing agreement says that
all furniture must be
taken in every night what happens then
if when they renew go to renew their
licensing agreement that the licensing
agreement is turned down because they
got permanent pictures on the pavement
of
course that's not to a planning issue no
i know it's not a planning issue but
it's
weighing on my mind
thank you chair
i think you just said what i was gonna
say actually i think we're deviating
away from matters of the planning
application uh
licensing which obviously we're not here
today to consider um there was just one
might also like to pick up on just so
members are very clear about this that
there was a informal officer meeting um
with the applicants prior to the
erection of this back last year uh i
believe it was last year which advice
was given about a temporary structure um
clearly this isn't a temporary structure
this isn't what the advice is based on
but there was that pre-application
discussion so that did take place
thank you sean
uh picking up on
retrospective applications sponsored
we
don't like record
retrospective in a way i've got to say
this council's put retrospectives in and
there's one
currently actually been registered
retrospective so you know
needs must when the devil drives and if
you're going to wait for planning
permission in some instances
it's more effective if you get on with
what you need to do and then apply
council of golf
thank you very much there miss jim um
just coming back on a point that counts
the loggers actually raised encounters a
christie race about the social behavior
gatherings um underneath this structure
um obviously i proved there'd be grants
applications subject to 24 months
minimum
duration time
i'd also like to may add a condition to
that again
where we have the removal of the benches
underneath the structure then
obviously they've already also got
the chance and entertainment shares back
out into this this to me is a
strikes a good balance
i think you're trying to be fair for
every every business on the key and
especially what counts a lot raised you
know it's not a favorite sport on it
because of these these benches being
actually secured in permanently because
of the residents so if we remove these
structure
you mean you mean the table the tables
yeah the same as those two they get
removed
and obviously temporary table shares go
in on a daily use i can see that then
striking no good balance
with captain america
that's acceptable i think that's what
should be done
i mean it would probably mean enough to
get rid of those you you can't really um
inside that building and bring them out
henry james you're pretty headed
and you have to put removable tables out
in every morning
some chairs from inside
right
nobody else wants to speak to this so
it's been
[Music]
can you just confirm the word and that
condition then that the
permanent tables and jazz will be
removed and replaced daily with
tables and chairs to be put inside well
the condition was that these are removed
every night whether they're put back
again in the morning i don't know or
other tables might be put back the
condition that counselor got madoff put
forward
was that we vote for 24 months
given permission for this for 24 months
and that these
picnic tables that are shown in the
photographs are removed every night
until it's replaced in the morning
that's it
okay
tell me a bit that katherine mcguff said
24 months minimum
i think we should
drop the minimum and just stay for 24
months
well it's 24 months and that's it
but he's talking about minimum
which means a little bit more
than just 25 performances
i would like to minimum remove it
if council watson would like that i have
no objection to do something crazy
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's appropriate that we can say
that under planning application um now
the license may still place something
obviously we're not a licensed committee
so i can't comment on that
just in terms of um the discussions
going on about the conditions relations
to the minimum
agree about removal of the working
minimum the classroom is happy with that
just ensure the position is precise and
to meet the test conditions
um in relation to the removal of any
chairs
as opposed to an additional condition
you may seek to amend the wording of
condition two which is on page 150 of
your committee report
um which currently leads the outdoor
supernatural should not be used between
the hours or between
ten hundred and something hundred hours
and we could then add additional text to
that condition
would say that
seating removal satisfied
[Music]
yeah so that that condition too would
read that the overall seating area
should not be used except between the
hours between 100 hours and 1700 hours
and the old seating will be removed
after that
mr i'm happy with that okay thank you
why is it 10 in the morning and not nine
in the morning
you're not around the morning before
[Music]
um that's what they've recommended i
think right where it came from was that
um
they asked the applicant by the agent
what hours they actually opened from and
i believe they opened the ten
um to publish four
um so that was where the condition
derived from but i mean i'm happy to
alter it to nine o'clock obviously if
anyone else comes and obviously they
have to open slightly earlier
um i must not say in terms of your
debate this was actually quite a
difficult one to write up because there
were some economic and social benefits
but clearly there is some harm to the
heritage assets
um
my comments were in terms of 24 months
there are other cafes and businesses
within the keats and we'll be interested
to see if any future applications come
to committee um i consider that 12
months was enough time to allow
covered rates potentially to be
decreased and for the um
for the owners to look at something else
more satisfactory um i think two years i
think potentially other businesses may
be slightly agreed by two years and i
think it would be different
i'm going to stop you there because
you're getting into
things that have nothing to do with this
stuff
what i'm discussing
[Music]
right
it's been
with that addition to two that the
tables are removed
i'm sorry to harp off well
they've bolted down picnic tables no way
do i think they are going to remove
those every night
and take them in the cabin where are
they going to start with the cafe i mean
i would have thought the logical answer
would just get rid of those completely
and bring out their spare yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and the other thing is that as we
mentioned an earlier opening if they
want you from nine o'clock
in the morning
but
i don't care who specified 10.
so
it was the environmental protection so i
do think the environmental protection
officer looked at the hours of what
key22 opens now
i i don't think there'll be any issues
from one o'clock
i'm happy with that um just to go back
to cancer lock obviously the structure
at the moment the benches are fixed to
the floor so i'm just giving the option
to the
the owners at the time to if these are
actually unbound from the floor removed
it then should help towards some of the
social behavior which chrisley touched
upon
he's trying to strike a happy medium you
know you're going to please unlock of
these others but you know just what's
before us at a moment
you know when i said that 24 months okay
thank you very much to the officer
station why should you sit there 12
months that's fine but that we all want
different views not a problem but it's
just i think alluded to now that these
tables and chairs have been in that cafe
already
which could be used again
to service where these maybe these
potential pensions might be else but
maybe they want to make a nice donation
to give it to a bit of town council
victoria park if they're whether they
would
somebody goes
i'm happy to purchase it for victorians
application anyways
[Music]
[Music]
24 hours which is condition one and
conditioned to
opening from nine in the morning till
1700 and any seating there has to be
removed
after 1700 hours and they put it back
out in the morning exactly samuel would
you please take the vote on that
recommendation thank
yes chair thank you councillor vouchers
paul
councillor brown
councillor christie
councillor craigie for councillor
lebanon poor councillor locke four
councillor golf four councillor watson
four
wise men
that's eight four and one against chair
have you seen that
[Music]
right that's where
a
[Music]
is the delegated decisions airbnb
applications on page 152
11
is the planning planning decisions pages
of 153
2061 listed delegated planning decisions
uh between 24th of september and the
21st of october
i'll start with the pages 153
keeping the eye open on the right here
everybody
thank you everyone